they are [ __ ] with me but I love it I
don't care now and I don't want to cause
a fight between you and I but I'm
someone's Tiger belly fans said that you
had said that my girlfriend was too hot
for me did you say that I probably did
on a couple of but if I did I probably
did
I mean did I listen bro
all right we're both guys from San Diego
you know I'm from San Diego right no I
don't I'm from Poway California I'm a
Titan no way oh yeah and then I live and
then I lived in La Jolla for a very long
time I work at the panickin in La Jolla
what yeah and then I look at that rust
restaurant too and I started doing
stand-up at the La Jolla comedy store so
you know I was born and bred in San
Diego so that's why you and I have a
connection for you so when you said that
my girlfriend was too hot for me it
really broke me a little bit oh my god
let me say something yeah okay and I
mean this from the bottom of my heart
yeah yeah go ahead she really is I'm
sorry I know but but guess what but
guess what guess what that makes you
look good that's right I mean hello
hello but you say what I forgot our
first name kalila I'm Colette Lila
you're the most compassionate forgiving
a charitable person to take him hey
Kayla it's a it's a 500 a seat right off
Mitch you buy if you buy him coffee like
cuz it doesn't work anymore write it off
man big [ __ ] charity all right so
what's the relationship with you with
Rose right now well you got it stay
tuned they're not done okay I'm having a
lot of fun with it yeah it's really like
I don't think I heard the story but when
the when the